[Music]
what is up everybody happy Friday how's
it going Persia here we got Ritchie
today what's going on and yeah happy
Friday yeah Friday um yeah you guys so
Grand Theft Auto five a classic it's now
available on Xbox game pass so of course
we were like you gotta play it it's a
dollar um so here we are this is what
we're doing today unfortunately we were
gonna try to run some of the online
stuff with like the DLC and everything
but with the game pass Ritchie couldn't
transfer his account over to the online
portion only over to the story mode
portion yeah so we're gonna start a new
story all the old campaign it's great in
this game so it's not a bad thing it
just we did want to try online but yeah
some account transfer technical
difficulties goofed me up this morning
so here we are here we are but it's all
good we're just gonna reminisce a little
bit and honestly when I was a you know
making stream and everything I was like
wow this game came out in 2013 it really
doesn't feel like if you know that long
ago it's still like so relevant online
especially but the story if I remember
should hold up pretty well like it's not
that old as far as like storytelling but
it's still a very active online
community so this game is still like not
off the radar yet yeah and we also
looked at this long list of like all the
DLC and add-ons like the history of the
add-ons for this game alone yeah like
every single year since released they
were dropping so much content they still
are yeah it is intensive this game is
still like like still relevant for sure
exactly so we aren't gonna hop on into
this brand spanking a new game yeah of
GTA 5 right from the start so yeah
thanks for joining us yes we're gonna
start here with the prologue that's a
little I think it might be a little loud
but oh here let me just turn down just a
smidge there we go okay so the prologue
begins 9 year before 9 years before the
main story which was a little title card
that I skipped over but that's it the
the games about to start
enjoy y'all let's get into it yeah yeah
when do you think GTA 6 is coming out
says Jordan no idea the way they're
updating this one so consistently yeah I
don't know either there are rumors
already but nothing concrete they're
good about keeping their lip seal their
Rockstar did you play the story mode for
this although my favorite gta's actually
by City oh cool it's a great choice I
love my city I love sand raise to5 is
great too hmm all right hey we just
talked about that Jordan asked what's
your favorite juicy hopefully by the
stream delay my answer came out like
after you angel says everyone has GC
already lmao I think this is more for
like the die-hard GTA fans who are like
I don't mind owning this on every single
console why not yeah I had it originally
on ps3 and I played that until they
stopped supporting it here we are
online anyway of course you can still
play the campaign collect the cash yeah
there's enough here for us all to enjoy
how you look at chichi let's roll
wish I had one hundred and seventy nine
thousand that's going to high Spurs yeah
here we go
time to switch over to Trevor there you
go be cool let's roll forget about our
third friend here our partner doesn't
look good for him if I don't remember
him finding cover spot by the way this
game you guys was 69 years
victus said I just started downloading
on the Xbox one s never played GTA 5
ever you know I feel like nowadays we're
constantly hearing from people oh wait
until to get this game when it's cheaper
well Victor definitely sees the
opportunity it won't get any cheaper
than this yeah especially for me because
I didn't have game pads because you
normally am our ps4 but have the one X
in the office
downloaded game pass for a dollar I
downloaded this game with your own
digital Hey
it was very good I don't want to shoot
my friend there we go okay should I
switch over let's see Michaels a little
closer to the action so many cops let's
go Jordan said he's never played GTA but
they definitely have their own charm to
them each one is different but like
they're all great I mean who's a bad GTA
I have like a least favorite but none of
them are terrible by any means let's go
let's go
I just always found like the aiming
system just so comically overpowered
something oh yeah so easy to just but it
makes me feel so good like Oh ding it
does I'm unstoppable yeah let's go
there's our ride out of here
oh yeah I'm gonna take control driving
here in a sec there's a there's a little
Easter egg in this opening part here we
cross over a little bridge that's over a
lake and the lake is iced over but if
you get out of the car I'm not good I'm
not gonna do it cuz I'm not sure exactly
where but if you get out of the car
check out the lake you'll see like a
frozen alien it looks like a xenomorph
yeah [ __ ] our drivers down oh you still
there he's in the backseat it's just our
driver guide oh there's the bridge
coming up just look up the YouTube video
I'm not gonna do it because I don't want
to be like totally wrong about where it
is and then the cops are gonna get it
oh you ned I wish TV for or if I would
come to switch wow that would be insane
that's incredibly demanding but you can
dream you know that game gets wild
sometimes
insert coin says if you've never played
it do it exactly yeah it helps that I
love this game but of course it helps to
play to have played because you know
what's going on what's there but we can
still enjoy the story use your real
names what city would you like to see
Grand Theft Auto 16 Frasier maybe like I
think it will actually be some little
crossover action or yeah like San
Andreas had a Vegas SF and LA smaller
parts of it I like that idea
it's like having all the previous city
is in like somewhere new and
be able to like fly to the other places
switch over not shoulder oh I just did
it like right when they mr. cutscene Oh
No
team Makani is's what's up Game five I'm
new to this channel by the way ball go
go go thanks for joining us there
screaming that a little different time
today but glad you're here with us
we usually stream at 11 a.m. we wanted
to make sure the download happened so we
had to wait yeah we even wanted to play
online but that didn't happen
unfortunately but it's always great no
regrets you know rag records there we go
now oh yeah I get to attend my own
funeral he's not talking smoking in the
cemetery mm-hmm areas Oh ding he live
real estate said I get sad when I please
cuz I have to kill innocent people that
probably have kids you know you think it
really it's real yeah but I actually
love that concept because I don't know
if you guys have seen the movie trailer
what's that oh man what's the name of it
it has Brian Reynolds in it and he's
basically an npc in a grand theft auto
styled game Oh said in one day he's like
you know it doesn't have to be like this
you know there has to be something
different Oh what was that movie called
it's coming out like this summary thing
I don't remember I think we saw a
trailer here I work for it it's pretty
funny and is your son James it's like
free guy or something like that yeah
he's a good kid a good kid why free guy
yeah yeah 1up guy he sits on his ass all
day smoking dope and jerking off
let's hop over huh that is a great intro
though maybe I shouldn't have skipped it
but he's in therapy years later and then
he meets up with Franklin just for a
second to ask for directions but this is
how we get to learn about Franklin like
it looks goofy and funny but I would
definitely want to see it oh man baby
I'm so glad I set the age restriction to
the proper right away right out the gate
alright I got a race Lemar he's gonna
sound so silly but in all the gtas I've
played I always just like to drive
around like a normal person like I'll go
the speed limit I'll obey all the
traffic stop signs that's definitely a
way to play it's like challenge yourself
you know it's like therapeutic I'm just
going for a nice cruise it's like a Los
Angeles simulator at that point although
there'd be way more cars exactly I like
stop at every stop sign little rusty all
but I remember being really smooth in
this game although I'm not the smoothest
with controllers breaking the law whoa
Lizzy does back to you it's nice
Boyet crash into the wall that guy just
goes eat my ass all right here we go
driving through the studio oh man
Lamar with these left with these quick
turns I can't hang like I said I'm rusty
I'm supposed to be winning this race
aren't ya Oh
oh my goodness version we'll have to
give you the control oh this is just
like a casual race first mission and I'm
really ruining it I guess I was slow-mo
youthful slow-mo driving oh yeah the the
prompt came up there on the left like
right and left thick right okay cool
one when traffic gets crazy I'm gonna
try that out for yelling to each other
across the car yeah it's like I'm on the
speakerphone and I'm also yelling like
Oh as if he's in range I remember at the
end of this race it gets a little easier
for me to cut you out but I still might
goof it up cuz you guys already know how
bad I'm doing no we're we're honest tale
we are I also don't know where the chick
like the finish point is it's like
simians place but I forget where that is
anyway you're just following it I'm just
falling or just getting a lay of the
land
jim-jim says this is my favorite game
ever made of the decade yeah look at
Lamar's car all right gotta lose the one
time whoa I'm in a pickle whoa Krypto
that's literally the perfect knee right
now he was like oh [ __ ] here we go again
yeah on game pass same city
you know there's Franklin's a lot like
CJ he just wants the good people like
his friends like lamorne stuff always
try to fudge it up whoa never CJ he
moved away from the beginning of San
Andreas he comes back from Liberty City
I'm just trying to lose the cops not
leave town get me out of here man
I should have just hid in somewhere look
at the freeway was a bad idea guys oh
[Applause]
yeah yeah there you go can't see me I'm
ruining the car still yeah here we go
some games they can't see you in the
bushes
right I am losing them on the radar
there's nothing no cops nearby good news
oh they're gonna make me drive so far
away though to get back to the
dealership I goofed
I deserve that
easy yeah come on let's go away those
stars you to go away oh man there's
another one up ahead alright if I don't
take that down I'm going crazy sorry I
was looking for Matt we're just gonna
drive right off this cliff
I didn't know how but I did it alright
was it back up I was like I would've
just drove off that cliff yeah rooo
inaudible whatever do you only work for
Simeon for a little bit whoa all right
let's go
virtual ones last time you went to LA a
little bit after I went to Universal oh
cool that's right Oh oh wow I just think
I obviously think of Los Santos when I'm
out there it's really modeled
worthlessly it's modeled so well after
the actual
this card is destroyed I should get no
money for this Liberty City was me
alright great
yeah what did I say I was thinking like
cuz you know since I lived in New York
for a long time I always really liked
games that like our model deputy right
yeah and I do like Liberty City but
after I played spider-man I would like
now this is the best there is so great
they even have there's this fear I used
to go to like all the time it's like
very relaxing obviously it's a pier I
was right next to the water and has like
this nice little grassy area it's great
and it's in Spider Man it is there I
purposely like went over there to look
for it when I started playing so I was
like this looks pretty good
that's so funny that's like something I
would do yeah Jimmy that's his name
Mike son I'm done for now though look at
the first those decals alright see you
later
wait isn't that my card yeah what's the
buffalo that's my card crypto can I get
a number 9 large number 26 fries that's
the order man view do you guys like see
this one see more like obsessed with six
[ __ ] first person driving is always
it's like stressful for me that's
something I could never shoot I couldn't
pull off because I only have the what
they call they don't have the ps3
version check all the book I don't know
a pretty shitty driver in this game I
mean all kinds of accidents Oh back home
here we are
low-key one of my favorite things is
like getting enough money to buy better
houses so fun online some [ __ ] on
your dick [ __ ] with that brain
surgeon the lawyer she [ __ ] wit you
wanna hang out no and then he starts
yelling are you making fun of your
haircut alright it's like you know your
real friends when you destroy each other
yeah and then calm later and be like
just try to get out the house and II
think I might switch over are their
Simeon did I dip I just the call I just
let me do what's air yeah can't you see
I'm trying get to my car got the stunt
plane alright there is a [ __ ] get over
here so I can give you the new repo list
alright dog I'll be around when I key to
change there we go
time to start working for Simeon
you're in line right across the street
[Laughter]
eventually though it'll prompt over to
switch to Michael and eventually Trevor
but for now we're working with Franklin
oh cool
dealerships right there Kryptos wants
GTA on mobile the old ones are there
yeah he was like we got Santa J's in my
city when are we getting four or five
then I thought it was a tall order Chris
which definitely gonna be a tolerator
for mobile yeah better make sure you
have like the best phone ever everyone
took my spot whatever these parking jobs
gave me right now well we're here this
is full speed I'm trying so good working
together for about a few months now
right which is why I am very honored to
announce to you that you are Employee of
the Month huh everybody gets upset about
this he's like I want a raise not a
shitty ward yeah me Lamar your nephew
Sachi with the twitch I gotta move
forward in my life it seemed like all I
do is that people tell me what to do and
I do it and nothing changed I tell you
what my boy you tell me exactly what you
want and I will very carefully explain
to you why it cannot be what today is
repossessing vehicles that fools have
purchased at exorbitant interest rates
together I never had a black son don't
know why he specified attention he's mad
because he didn't get
some cars I should don't you play you
know would take us ten years into the
mission touching every read literally
the story on my lips I run one and get
like a movie violation I think about
running it right
we're here like now that we're playing
it again I'm like man it was a long time
where I was yeah you should know a block
makes a difference here we go someone
these garages hmm this a block makes a
difference it's so true
nothing Oh
I mean couches come on water help out
calling it out Oh what if you walk to
that one face Oh like you people creep
it up on no we're doomed now weren't
[Music]
right hold our tea
well yeah that's take cover but I'm
trying to pull out the gun there it is
no that's my phone oh my god there we go
yeah I thought it was a great dude
[Music]
yeah I have this broken aim right now
yeah well wrong wrong place to take over
here oh right up there I was like
looking out too far ahead is he gone you
know the red dot is still down the map
there you go let's get oh shoot she took
cover I was like we're in the Margo
[Music]
there the okay the market care
I don't shooting the gas yeah this is
what I should have done much cooler
tomorrow
I need him all right let's go getting in
my car
sir I says this game needs a sequel
already I feel like they're just adding
so much DLC that they're either working
on the next iteration like Loki while
they were pumping out like DLC or
they're just focusing on the DLC to give
themselves time before they have to
start on who knows playing the best the
best way to get there cuz now I lost
this guy he's so far away here we go
he's not that far now all right
few blocks this looks like the Grove I'm
pretty sure it is alright everybody you
know what
all those people are my way they got to
go all right I'm trying to dodge them I
was trying to but now they're just in
the way they maybe drive through here
they made me drive through shield your
eyes are tat don't look wow I mean I
don't know I'm trying to think what I
have the reactions to jump to the side
instead of just blatantly standing in
front of the car I don't feel like you
were driving that that fast like
unreactive yeah
but then again I don't know no it could
be so far off like charging straight for
me ever so alright now well I don't want
to ruin the bike cuz I was just gonna
like run into him oh yeah we have to
repossess it okay I could shoot with
this car out the wind or this gun out
the window
I always remember turning being very
annoying when you're trying this whoo oh
no they did that okay oh I believe in
there there we go I feel like when I was
younger I would feel like my parents are
so against this game and just this
opening mission alone I'm like that
makes sense
I'll still never forget the like it was
like a reddit post or something of like
a person who worked at like Game Stop or
something and this mom came in like
super upset
oh they're like sold that they convinced
her basically to buy this for their kid
and she just thought it was like a
regular ol game and she walked in on him
like in one of those sexy look at the
strip exactly no you were super mad
oh geez whoa like see if this why all
parents should be gamers and then though
which games coming out are what they are
and what they're about yeah never have
to run into that problem ever again
although Grand Theft Auto is always in
the news about like how bad it is and
how it's always you know take - and
rocks are always getting sued they have
been for a while now
spike is kind of
all right well kind of slow yet
it told we almost outran now Sayle right
yeah I guess it's just in the wrong
hands there you go I'm leaning forward I
don't know I don't know if that works
anymore
hey any improvements on this game at all
I'm assumed any X improvements I'm
assuming means it being on Xbox I'm not
sure I think it's just a straightforward
yeah as far as I know it's it's the Xbox
one version just just normal I don't
think there are any extra graphical
enhancements as far as I could tell but
you know
[Music]
well he said why all the hype because
the game from 2013 Kim's game pass well
you know you have to have a true love
for this series to be excited about it I
suppose but it's pretty much a classic
at this point even though it still feels
pretty new yeah it's still like
especially if you haven't played it you
should give it a shot cos like I said
this morning I downloaded game pass for
a dollar and just downloaded this game
like nothing so if you haven't played
sure but it's also might is also fun for
us to revisit for sure yeah and we
actually did see a few people in chat
who hadn't played it before and now's
your chance
oh that's right yeah early on in the
chat let's just watch the bike and give
it back to Simeon
alright what you're embarrassing about
MK 11 MK 11 yeah that game is definitely
gory oh yeah yeah it's so boring I was
reading about how some of the developers
legit or getting PTSD from developing it
because they would have to reference
like real life stuff and even though it
might not have been like human stuff or
some of it was actually what I heard but
you know they would look at like you
know animals getting butchered and stuff
like that to see how like the blood
reacted and all this other cruelly yeah
really really intense
that's that next level attention to
detail yeah
oh man I didn't go through the front
door normally I'm back here I have a
bullet hole on my back gaming snake says
are you guys hype about halo Infinite I
think I lochia
always type about anything halo related
and regardless of what it is yeah I'm
really curious to see what they're going
to do I'm more so one of like the
multiplayer halo heads and you know I
know some people only play it for like
the campaign and some people only player
multiplayer yeah so man good times with
Halo
oh yeah I feel like it's a staple like
anybody who plays games has at least
touched one of the Halo games by now
yeah it's been over a like quite a few
years now most of us have played at
least one alo let's go
something I actually like about all the
streaming services is one you get access
to all these games that you might not
have played before but they're generally
popular amongst you know the gaming
community for example GZA is one of
those and then being able to just play
good games that you never played before
yeah it opens your eyes to stuff you've
been missing out on yep I felt that way
really I really really felt that way
about the most recent god of war I had
never played that gotta work before
played it fell in love with it with
kicking myself for waiting that long to
play it and it was only really out for
like a year before I played it yeah and
then this one's of analysis 2013 and
some people haven't played it so you're
in for a treat I feel like that's
something I really really like about the
streaming streaming services being able
to play stuff you haven't played before
and then finding something you really
resonate with yeah it's really cool tech
guy says game Pass rocks I'm a plus one
to that here's Michael's house we made
it y'all
this is where we meet Michael all REE
meet him is the world where entry
introduced to find a way in the boughs
jump over the oh man do I have to who
are you I guess I do
probably yeah look at that to enter
sorry wasn't playing all the way down I
should have done this the game wanted me
to go into stealth mode no I'm not
alright well let's open Alvaro asked
what concert we're playing on we are
playing on the Xbox one s o X X I mean
Xbox one X mm I just goofed that up he i
watch can't get do the window hmm cats
be cool ah hello I missed the prompt was
I took like open this up try to open
this up are like he put his hand down
there first
all right I can't believe I missed the
prompt backdoor hate to know I felt like
I was supposed to open the garage like
straight up I missed something for sure
Chad if you remember chime in Willy said
round back to the window the window
which windows climb on the other side of
the house
Oh open oh yeah there we go cool you
like barely missed walking into the area
that the prompt was yeah talking that
gamer trash oh that's a sister
okay I'm just gonna go to the garage
[Music]
shoot okay they're not they're not okay
let me choose the garage though this way
I have a feeling yes oh snap the swag
bear said I just did subbed alright
thanks so welcome
hope you're having a great fry yay and
Happy New Year
whoa it's like what's the allotted time
to say Happy New Year right like either
the first time you see in a year because
if that's the case sometimes you might
not see someone for the first time until
like July yeah grace period we yeah we
talked about this yesterday my
girlfriend and I I think my cutoff for
any anyone at all is like the first week
of the new year
I look around
just keep driving where you're going all
right I'm not gonna drive down right
cause like I just got the car and look
at it the way you're going about this I
guess
you
credit fraud credit fraud a serious dude
I just work the [ __ ] repo I
appreciate a kid who follows like their
game you think so - Sweden but I'm in
2021 by the way o is the future always
appreciated spongebob reference fifa
world cannot be me or to you hope NYC is
treating you well I miss it very much
very very much well here we go I
remember this part
Michael takes matters into his own hands
after I parked the car here hello from
Norway great your might I have to do
this it rounds the back of your skull
myself I look like a [ __ ] joke to you
liquid says have we played this game
before
yes yeah it's been years but I played it
as soon as it came out and I played
online for like a year and a half year
here we go big for job well done
now Michael okay let's go Jesus these
combos I'm ready to dodge but there you
go
dodging there you he's added yeah we
wanted to play online today because like
Richie mentioned Hugh's played a lot
both the campaign and online with the
game pass he was unable to transfer his
character from his old on
account to the Xbox class version so we
decided to just reminisce on story mode
what's dead-house exactly sorry about
that for those wanting to check out some
online but uh yeah we had like a we get
to play it again
it's always nice going back to the old
classics switch between Michael and
Franklin alright well unless Michaels
got anything oh look I have a my first
Michael mission at home there well I
need a car might as well kick Simeon
while he's down and steal this car
[Music]
there we go you can't rock the tunes
that's okay
whoa
exactly tech guy that's like my trash
talk for every fight take that and that
and then
[Music]
yeah I do think it's really interesting
how this was on like PS now service and
then they stitch two doors and ex
passers so it's making its around across
the streaming services who knows maybe
Stadium someone in the chat earlier said
that not on the ps4 anymore I'm not sure
if they meant the store because it's on
you remember if it's my goodness
honestly next year's new like generation
of consoles are all gonna be so powerful
and good that it doesn't mean it's not
really even in a matter I think which
console you play because they're all
just gonna be so much better than the
equipment we have now and I think cross
play is gonna make a giant wave so we're
truly entering the time to be alive as
game rooms we are excited for the future
here like once Cod fully implemented
like cross play across every meal a day
I felt like it worked so well - at least
for cod I don't what other games have
cross play after coming back to Cod
after the data and playing with like in
cross play with PC players yes
definitely getting absolutely destroyed
whereas in the beta I felt like it
wasn't that prominent but I took a
little break came back to it Massacre it
was all rip if you like that though
sometimes ok I can save that carb I
don't want him I just wanted do the next
mission
yeah yes carries me says free real
estate I mean if you've played the games
that were like designed for that
platform they feel pretty good but I
definitely seen a lot of footage of like
super bad like and everything so yeah I
don't
yeah Michaels is chilling outside none
of that scarring a drink after knocking
out Simeon catching up with Michael nine
years later after the prologue his life
[Music]
[Music]
stuck in the 80s
she is really serious about that Wow I
offered him a beer and now he's like
nope here sit yeah gonna rob me again
man I never robbed you go whatever you
want to call it I really don't care
gotta do for you see I just came by to
see if there's something I can help you
with hello candy car yes we are shooting
a little bit later than usual today
usually extreme at 11 a.m. this was a
massive download so he had displeasure
back a lot of bears yeah some hiccups
this morning but it's all good we wanted
to celebrate a classic here we go what
the yotz been stolen alright I'm coming
for my boat oh boy Franklin's here right
there my darling boy is in trouble
Oh do you remember this mission I have
to chase them the boat that's being
towed on the freeway gonna be crazy I
know this all of my belongings
I think somebody in the track earlier
was mentioning how they hated this
mission yeah oh man I'm in for a treat
aren't I
today and welcome thank you guys all for
being here
pn3 today Willie said I hope you did it
first time wishing you luck thanks man I
need that you come repo it
no thank you all right I ain't your
homey one you want to impress real all
right I won't impress some slip away
[ __ ] still teach you a thing or
two maybe help you open the door to all
the joys that boat related parenting
issues entail so all my help you get
this boat back right that you are my
friend oh yeah by the way my son is in
the back of the boat kidnapped um does
xbox game pass version include
multiplayer yes it does
but you cannot transfer your current
account over to it so that was yeah that
was just me I think at least right now
the thing you're gonna go for that it
was it like a system problem it was like
a new problem oh I think so like
oh my god
but yeah a few uh last time I played
this was like the ps3 and back then you
were able to transfer your account once
over to a new a new system whoo but the
window on that has closed and I wasn't
able to transfer my online account show
you that slow-mo oh yeah
actually just try to take out that guy
there we go oh my car is smoking y'all
bad news it's hard to do that and drive
I stopped driving I'm on my way
I can't Jeff Barry yeah I stopped
accelerating
Wow way too stressful
oh yeah
my son food all right let's catch up I
don't want to use the cinematic mode at
this moment Jimmy oh I don't want to
think of that guy I'm going full speed
pedal the metal can at a let me get
those no that's only online I think I
remember no there goes oh [ __ ] Franklin
okay okay cinematic can we slow down for
Franklin's sake nah we got a buzz gonna
jump in yeah they're right the boat all
right all right now
shut up Jimmy
this cars after Osnap gaming sleep says
I'm gonna go get some pizza anybody else
want some yes what we'll take double
pepperoni for D or the order from a
chain or do you have a place in your
viola co-locate get it though they
change their sale which has maybe order
from unless we love Domino's at our
house too but you remember the if you
buy two or more immediately stopping
people as their 599 each oh they changed
it take out only oh they change it to
two or more large pizzas throw 11 than I
need so they like double it Chris said
this mission is so fresh I'm glad I'm
just did I did it
real estate says I'll get a little extra
large pizza box still teacher no pizza
just survive it's a box
fun fact like my second job ever
I worked at Papa John's ready to summon
and fold one time I did that oh gosh
I worked out at Dave & Buster's and I
did the roll-ups for my entire shift it
was a four hour shift of all the coins
so I did the roll-ups of napkins with
porky yeah that was Billy because I
hated my actual job there so they put me
like in this room this laundry room
here's tuck you in the closet alright do
this then and like cool I don't the deal
with people like customers hell yeah
thanks for tuning I'm sorry thanks for
joining us they said love you stream but
when I lived in New York I definitely
had a bunch of specific pizza places I
really really liked to go to that were
not jeans or some of them were semi
jeans okay so like three or four
locations yeah is good to boots all men
are so good they're a little bit douchey
but they have this vegan slice and I'm
not even vegan but it's like my favorite
thing there Wow up in Washington Heights
called Pizza Heroes super good I'm not
gonna deck out this car it's my
daughter's car so what's up ounce
it says crystal on the license we got it
back in working order though that's a
radio it is the radios like who is
talking a smart car forgot those were in
this game were that they view models
real cars like real actual makes and
models
yeah thanks really R when we were
fighting like the cholo guys they had
like you have a great night as well
gaming snake I gave me to catch you next
time for some pizza yeah we should
stream with pieces from fighting Persia
Chris they can't do a live which or
three next we did which ur stream when
it was on switch resident Richard yeah
that is available on you know it's a pod
now if you want to watch you guys for
The Witcher fans in the chat as you guys
who didn't see the Netflix you want to
get your tapes on it because I watched
some of it it's really good obviously
very well produced I never really played
The Witcher series in its entirety
awesome but I could see game related
elements like when he's like in combat I
haven't got any way because I didn't
play Witcher 3 and I want to it just
feels like you ordered it more can you
play the game
I'll definitely understand and
appreciate it more however it's still
really good that's good that I can be
good on its own chat is agreeing New
York Pizza is the best new your
everything else it's always hilarious
for me when I like Joe to events and
stuff and like Chicago or something in
there like nah no no no I kind of in the
water y'all it is in the water they say
I I never I don't I'm like all pizza but
yeah there are some shirts that I like
more than
other others and when I finally did go
to New York for the first time I was
like oh yeah this is where it's at
also because of convenience yeah because
there it's good pizza everywhere in New
York that's just what it is like it's
everywhere even like the economy Pizza
spots like there's two boots which is
the bougie one but then there's two bros
which is like literally dollar slice
that's what yeah so good even they're
like cheapest pizza when I was really
really I was like I have $5 this week oh
yeah that's the pizza slice no goodbye
[ __ ] I still have this car I found that
guy if you ever do make your way to New
York one day get yourself a slice of
pizza I wanted that car there will be
others I'm just driving around this car
that I kind of found at simians place
macGruber it said anyway pizzas smells
of rats you must have some pretty good
smell in rats then Joe saying smells
like rats
oh no that good if I owned a rat that
smell like New York Pizza I feel like
I'd be so conflicted we call them so
delicious but you're a rat I really feel
about all right I'm cutting through
traffic let's go back to uh actually
still playing as Michael no I'm Franklin
again
are you heading out swag bad thanks for
today and we will see you later see you
swag bear hope to catch you next time
just turn here
I think you move you [ __ ] oh my
gosh I'm getting my phones blowing up
here watch out no texting and driving
right I'm distracted driver
it's very California of me okay I can
get my there it is my white car back
wait what's across the street that's the
question may I skip I don't know but I
would just assume that they don't yeah
I'm gonna call no anything that like was
a carrier for the plague at some point
in history might not also watch this
horribly cursed video likes kidding and
shaping rats into the sheets of like
chicken pieces and right yeah it was it
was traumatizing
I wouldn't even eat a chicken would
either I'm very sensitive stuff it was
cursed video I wish I had never seen it
let's go let's go Hollis hold towtruck
Connor says OMG what game is this you
ever hear of a little game called gta5
Koenig I said why Persia I know I know
and a curse story but when else am I
gonna have a segue and it wasn't even
like easy do fun sexy
I thought they just posted like fights
whoa I'm also just like flabbergasted Oh
like there's no way that you know you
read the title okay there's no way
chicken nuggets already bad enough all
right it's crashing upon tree they have
the pink goose here I still eat them
though I love chicken nuggets I'm not
above them whatever well yeah if there
were made of rats I'd be like mmm this
is concerning I mean maybe I won't eat
them anymore okay we're here calzone I
love ya oh man now I gotta be extra
careful maybe I shouldn't run a red
light come on go go go my turn oops good
thing I'm not a real tow truck driver I
can barely do it in a video game
before you was the wannabe when you just
was and I remit any when JB before y'all
was dopey
[ __ ] changes you the one turf stop
JB's smoking but he games right look at
the best hospitals Wendy's Mike it's for
the win I love McDonnell gets us all
because we're probably all raised on
that like our parents advice oh yeah
even passing by one you're like oh come
on man and there I love their breakfast
you of course
I think my least favorite fast-food
nuggets are Burger King although those
are the cheapest they are they are I
like them you can get like ten nuggets
for a dollar or something yeah they're
always like sale it's a little
concerning they got the area smarts
they get real finicky when we don't
leave it in the right place whatever is
this good enough sugar oh sure I got out
of the car without dropping it sorry
okay let's unhook hold it there you
chucky cheese microwave pizza real
estate man after it's already microwave
after watching that shane dawson knew
about their pizza confirmed although I
hadn't had chucky cheese pizza and like
you know more than a decade right after
watching that video I was like I'm never
going Batman it's cuz when we
legitimately ate there we were children
or yeah I feel like I never I'm not
gonna notice that I don't feel like that
happened volume is I felt like their
quality maybe it's dropping me they
started pulling some bull ass
oh god that videos off
it is it is a funny thing whoa I think I
dunno we're talking about just go search
check your cheese conspiracy yeah it's
pretty funny yeah it is wool sad Oh
weird definitely funny the results
laughing I'm home now he's in my garage
oh come on yeah those dopes Davis is
supposed to lift up the car not dragon
before we hop the dog I need a friend
like that running buddy yeah already
that's me right there actually that's a
big mood real estate man you need to
calm down and freak me out about Chucky
trees even more
hey they're trying though they're out
here running there is there's chop just
gonna say that I feel like that game was
modeled after jeez when you're a kid all
pizza tastes good you like school yeah
it was like ragu and like some shitty
fake cheese but I was all about it
instead of like pepperoni you had like
little key tiny cubes of pepperoni yeah
mystery meat Bagel Bites Bagel Bites i
like where the little pizza pockets
Totino's pizza rolls yeah like pizza
rolls more though you do I was just
about to say those
age well for me it tastes good anymore
that's me I was like okay do they change
the recipe or did like I change did I
grow so chop is in the back I got a
drive extra careful Chris said hi mike
reading zombie are I never even played
the original did you iLike or games
that's a different style like where you
have to upkeep everything like press all
the right buttons to make sure you're
not caught like some things don't change
in Los Santos balls and balls are still
a problem going top is fine I see them
in the backseat there you're tilting
Auggie right now let's hear a lack of
slow-mo driving am I still really there
you go there that's for you miss Laurey
yeah oh no chop he's gonna throw up I
forgot nope no one I forgot all about
that because it's not implemented in
online mode if I remember correctly so I
just stopped using app although maybe I
can be corrected on that maybe it was in
some way
hey what's up bull ain't you little
mojitos cousin yeah yeah we came here at
the right time to stop this from going
down I guess you Marquez case is
Insignia oh I mean it's that he likes
the correct thing right that's my I got
a drive like a maniac while choppers in
the car no wrong way let's go let's go
top is angry though watch out dude oh my
god you were literally going like 2
miles in an hour and he went flying good
all right no no we good we're going
downhill Pro Gideon and that is correct
the book honestly any any reason for us
to play a game we like on the stream we
will find rear we will do it
for everyone still asking actually no
until they ask me something but for
those earlier us we have a reason it
just came out on game yeah oh look
that's for you no that's not unlimited
it's the bottom right bar bottom left
the yellow bar oh man I could not have
made that turn without you need my
avenged do you have like a souped up
white unmarked van at your house yeah
500 horsepower of my van how are we
having a regular come oh yeah I like how
he was laid out in the middle of street
and all of a sudden he took off running
he did yeah I thought he actually died
and I've taken that motorcycle it just
kind of ran past it chop is on it chop
is on the pace oh wait wrong way
the bus what am i climbing here the
fence not even on this over here you're
chopped once you go near the roof side
job my dog
oh no and he's losing the culprit Oh cuz
there's a gate yeah there we cam 3/4
come on jump or go I love that that
security guard like no good Samaritans
enjoy your stroll oh man my stamina is
slowing down no I'm gonna hurt come on
chop Oh same that's what I was thinking
come on chop I'll cover you chop here we
go no way alright I don't think I'm in
control now I'm not moving him okay but
if I find him using chopping I can yeah
hmm
where'd he go I thought he got on the
moving train
that would have been the smart thing for
him to do yeah just a lowly criminal oh
I think chops onto something no I'm
usually like a first person fan but I
feel like in this game specifically I
prefer in me too it's like how I learn
to play the first time yeah I think
there is funny things to be seen in
first person though GTA vibe or read
dead 2 and VR Chris that sounds fun
actually chop oh man he sees another dog
I remember this chop come back please
brown chicken brown cow come on chop
we're trying to work come on man guy you
can't go first prisoner oh you're frozen
out oh my gosh chop well oh I got to go
actually manually remove him oh my bad
get up i grazed him and he went roll it
I'm sorry me too oh here we go now we
can open these up chop I roll them over
at him I apologize chat if I just
murdered your eardrums but
seeing like ragdoll physics come out of
cheong just legitimately
come on yeah okay where did Lamar go art
[Music]
is most characters most of the main
characters are modeled after their
real-life counterparts including Lamar
he looks just like the voice actor yeah
okay chop I'm sorry yeah shut up back
there
I play 400 hours man there's a counter I
must be like pissing you off with how
poorly I'm doing but thanks for tuning
in hopefully haven't played the story
[Music]
unlockable the van says Lamar
yeah man what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
[ __ ]
I was getting us pay what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you that was a good phone
[Music]
playing games
chillin chillin charm I really
appreciate that
we do it for y'all you know well mission
accomplished let's see what's up if I
can hang out with Michael is that an
option okay I've got to finish the
mission first
great cool that is an expensive phone
yeah they threw it out the window
whoops
let's see here we go I miss chopped
already me too I have two available
missions with the both of them let's go
to Michael see what's up yeah on the
other side of town up in the hills
well is he where is he oh he's in the
cab
oh I'm driving a cab with the help today
home sweet home
why do they put me in a taxi though so
funny
yeah pickup truck oh wait what is this
this one's highlighted
hmm let's go in the house first let's
see the Michael mission I'm home man Oh
Amanda his wife Tracy yo yo
oh I remember this now - rackets and
Michael don't play tennis right now he's
not playing 150 bucks an hour - [ __ ] my
wife tourism underrated insult
okay I'll come oh my god I remember what
this leads to I just want to jump anyway
cuz we have 10 minutes left let's go
I called them Franklin we're gonna go
unfortunately we won't be playing the
online portion commander gene Shepard
yeah we had some technical difficulties
trying to set that up I thought I had it
unlocked but I did okay this truck is
slidy and I got to the music down
oh that's the in-game music good to use
out the way
no one's right there what you're falling
Arrancar oh yeah Oh kid you got juice I
did I'm gonna lose on okay they gave me
a marker to use I was a distracted
driver shame so letter V art chitchat
right now and I always have to ask
ever since I've seen the movie ready
player one if they had virtual reality
reality to that extent how many you guys
honestly I didn't like the book and I
thought I wasn't gonna like the movie
that's cool normally it's the other way
around burger king CJ said what level
are you in online on your main account
Richie oh I was a level level 100 mm
like I had just cracked through the
hundred for like a year and then they
stopped I played for like a year and
then they stop supporting PlayStation 3
so I kind of that's where I stopped I
didn't get a you know Xbox 1x so much
later and then I couldn't transfer my
account over it was too late Oh get back
in the truck do it I'm running my mouth
losing the mission here all right that's
why we have the truck you remember this
mission Persia what happens know you're
about to find out let's pull this guy's
house down yeah the fact that conman
also this is not as how
we learn later he hid out here but not
his place
the back fill on the balcony I go inside
again not that guy's house either
that's basically what you were saying
person
just checking out the cluster gate I
never really got to experience the first
person because I only had behind me oh
yeah they chasing you man this truck
wasn't built for speed
okay drive yeah Franklin help me out man
oh they're gonna make me beat Franklin
watch
oh well it's an option it'll speed
things up here
I know Elmo he's a king easy easy
wait did the drivers okay
more coming no yeah yeah got him okay
[ __ ] cool good I don't the drivers gonna
wanna know
although his driving is not looking much
better yeah I was gonna say uh because
actually it kind of looks like my
shooting driving
look at the car wrong button
I know I of all the songs they didn't
want to turn off you sound kind of man
you just be greedy about a Mexican
underworld ambassador to Los Santos
trust me we handled it whoever the [ __ ]
Marty Madrazo is we sit on it
oh you find out in the next mission I
had no idea was gonna get that hot I
forgot how hot this game starts like
right away we're doing all these well I
mean it's good it started it any other
way I'd be mad not mad but little
disappointed [ __ ] here we go already
they pull up to my house ponytails how'd
they get in our gate who are you ya know
you're in front of my house he really
gave no he knows exactly who he is the
place like yeah here you go
I think Martin's madrazo good boy do it
and give him a little of a background
man mister madrazo mister madrazo is a
legitimate businessman who was
wrongfully accused of running a Mexican
American gang and a narcotic ring but
the charges were dropped because of the
witnesses came up missing helico he's
sort of defending him because he wants
to just save face yeah these guys are
the same they're the same haircut
I thought the owner was banging my wife
well there was a strange house for a
tennis coach take it straight clearly
yeah yeah well Natalya well near the
hotel well you finally revealed one [ __ ]
sure good
and I'm guessing here that their rebuild
will be somewhere in 2.5 million range
of course great great oh boy oh well at
least he lived because that guy could
have easily just shot him right there he
knows where he lives now everything at
her
so what name looks like I'm gonna have
to postpone my retirement
I'm mortgaged up to my eyeballs look I
only know one way to make money though
I'm gonna have to give an old friend a
call the the wheels are turning in his
head I think he's in town somewhere I'm
gonna have to track him down
just give me a little alone time
all right Oh some alone time
quite the start to their friendship here
all right you guys that is actually
gonna wrap it up for us today Grand
Theft Auto 5 is now available on the
Xbox game pass so if you like gta5 or
I've never had the chance to play it and
you have game pass or if you don't have
game pass it's a dollar you probably
have it by now if you have an xbox but
it's a dollar it's a dollar today have
fun yeah and yeah thanks for tuning in
catch us every weekday at 11 a.m. we ran
little late today but that's cuz we were
getting all the GTA things in order
yeah thanks for hanging in there thanks
for tuning in exactly and thanks for
being really awesome to you guys it was
fun chatting and a fun playing some GTA
again
I hope you guys have a good one have a
happy Friday and have a great weekend
we'll see you guys next week bye